jeder mal eine menge los in diesen tagen
theresa may hat heute sehr emotional
ihren rücktritt angekündigt aber das
werden wir nicht
engländer die gefühle zeigen will keiner
sehen dafür dafür ist aber wie sie
sicher wissen in österreich was sehr
schönes passiert hc strache neulich noch
fdp chef und vizekanzler hat sein land
in eine fette regierungskrise gestürzt
und zwar im vollsuff quasi alarmstufe
blaue in wien
ich habe mir direkt einen neuen vorspann
gestellt
[Musik]
die heuer ihre freunde aktueller wiener
schmäh zum gemeinsamen abschnüffeln ist
das ein hammer ist das nammer die
österreichische regierung dieser feuchte
traum aller rechtspopulisten platz wegen
einer nacht auf ibiza oder ist das nicht
schön für mich so was wieder beweis dass
es doch einen gott gibt meine damen und
herren dfb ist raus im september gibt es
in österreich neuwahlen und auf eine art
ist man als deutscher ja fast schon
neidisch man versuchen sich vorzustellen
dass kanzlerin merkel oder vizekanzler
scholz besoffen auf ibiza hocken und die
deutsche republik olaf scholz kann ich
mir allenfalls auf valium einer ostsee
vorstellen sie haben das ja verfolgt hc
strache wird heimlich gefilmt wie er
sein land an eine russin verkauft an
eine oligarchen nicht wie wir heute
wissen mit nicht nur eine nichte war ja
wie er sich um kopf und kragen redet
über korruption und illegale
parteienfinanzierung wahnsinn
vorher muss man auch sagen egal was
dieser sprache sagt es klingt ja immer
wieder licht der muttertag ist ein ganz
besonderer ehrentag unserer mütter
großmütter und urgroßmütter nicht mal
dass graf matti möglich
sie wollten nicht fürs kotzen klatschen
das kann das niveau beibehalten
gut der strache könnte jetzt natürlich
tatsächlich nach dem film den wir
gesehen haben florist werden denn alle
seine anderen jobs ist ja los seit
dieser woche
welch ironie welche uni der mann der am
laufenden band rassistisches seubert
sätze wie willst du eine wohnung haben
musst du nur ein kopftuch tragen der
stolpert am ende über ja erfrischende
ehrlichkeit und wodka red bull verfolger
und wirklich eine echte oligarchen
ich vertraue dir blind bußee
red bull beendet karriere
dem fahrzeug
dafür seien die wache
ich saß ehrlich ekelhafte blogger aber
hier war sie echt mal für was gut und
natürlich läuft straches opfer
inszenierung das kennen wir von
populisten längst auf hochtouren es eine
neue dolchstoßlegende finstere mächte
raum mich gegen meinen willen betrunken
gemacht wahrscheinlich der mossad und
die russin war heute viel zu schaffen es
war ein typisch alkoholbedingt das
machogehabe ja es war nicht so viele
geschichten geschichten das übrigens
auch der täter von straches
autobiografie aber das ist eine andere
geschichte und surfen ist hier überhaupt
keine ausrede wenn man darüber nachdenkt
denn es gab ja auch nach ibiza noch fpd
kontakte zu der falschen oligarchen
was stimmt ist dass alkohol in der
österreichischen geschichte insgesamt
tatsächlich eine sehr große rolle spielt
österreichs geschichte
das hat schon arg vorne als der sitz fuß
über die alpen wollte frisches idee weil
der vollmond so fett wurde im schnee
schlafen jetzt liegt der druck und der
mozart erst der fall war
der hatte mit vier promille und rexam
komponierte unhörbar oder süße der
blumen die wollen viele deutsche so zu
dass den schieren karstadt mit der roten
jacken tatort und wendig jahre hitler 18
auch dort sie nicht jeden tag zwei
bürgermeister einige straßen da war der
bestimmtes arschloch als paranoid
erzeugt wurden aber das erzähle man
anders laufen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
doch
der österreichischen geschichte
ja da gibt es ohne ende beispiele oder
glauben sie der baumgartner wäre
nüchtern aus dieser raumkapsel
gesprungen so was bedeutet straches aus
jetzt für sebastian kurz den jüngsten
sie kanzler aller zeiten naja montag
montag kriegt er erst mal ein schönes
misstrauensvotum unser basti hier hat
die fpö mit seiner koalition noch erst
salonfähig gemacht inklusive rassismus
anderthalb jahre wurden sämtliche
skandale und ausfälle stumpf ignoriert
vom ratten gedicht über die nähe zu
rechtsradikalen gruppierungen bis hin zu
immer wiederkehrenden einzel film also
ich will nicht klugscheißern aber wieder
kehrende einzelfälle sind per definition
keine einzelfälle österreicher können
mich mal durch naja sebastian kurz
lassen sie mich das noch mal sehr
deutlich sagen so süßer ist sebastian
kurz ist kein kanzler der mitte ist ja
nicht ist ganz simpel ja ganz simpel wer
sich mit leuten wie strache ins bett
legt wie er hier hat die bürgerliche
welt verlassen der hc hat früher an
wehrsportübungen der wiking jugend
teilgenommen
java neonazi im orf hanse diese
wahrheiten häufig schon mal weg gibt
hier im reich da hab ich das sagen
neonazi
immerhin hat kurz denn innenminister
herbert kickl regelrecht rausgeschmissen
den mann der gesagt hat er möchte
flüchtlinge an einem ort konzentrieren
pickles herzensthema ist übrigens der
aufbau einer reiterstaffel die pläne
scheitern weil es ihm nicht gelingt
genügend pferde aufzutreiben
ja schade er hat wohl leider zu wenig
rechte förder zusammengekriegt das
passiert das passiert meiner mutter so
was
[Applaus]
negativ
die sogenannte konservative revolution
von wien ist offiziell geschichte
abgesagt und zum glück haben unsere
deutschen politiker von anfang an vor
genau dieser populisten regierung
gewarnt
ja alexander dobrindt zum beispiel hat
2017 ja noch direkt am wahlabend erkannt
dass das war mitte rechts gewonnen
werden können
das ist auftrag auch gerade für die
beiden unionsparteien und da war der
doppel noch nicht mal besoffen so was
lernen wir jetzt als deutsche aus dem
fall strache der kollege ulrich von
heesen hat seine konsequenz bereits
gezogen und ist gerade österreicher
geworden
wir schalten wir live nach wien ulrich
sehr komisches timing warum ausgerechnet
jetzt warum weil es hier lustig ist
österreich ist überhaupt das lustigste
land europas sogar die rechten sind hier
luft dick
bei uns sind sie doch immer so
verkniffen guckte denn bauland doch an
wie so ein sprechendes magengeschwüren
der strache dagegen im ibiza video diese
körperspannung
da sitzt das t shirt wie angegossen auf
seinem stählernen body das ist ein
mannsbild ein kerl mit anderen worten
der ist richtig dumm 110 kilo pures
christus drohen um den reinzulegen
brauchst du nur einen russischen akzent
und partiten so lustig finde ich den gar
nicht hc hat sich mehrfach als fan der
identität in bewegung lautet ja klar der
strache ist richtig rechts und
brandgefährlich aber im kern bleibt er
trotzdem ein versoffener kirmes prolet
einer der im zweifelsfall immer über die
eigene eitelkeit stolpert der stritt sie
findet sich so geil das ist schon
körperlich weh tut
[Musik]
doch nicht wirklich vom bürgern dies in
den kräutergarten müssen los vermutete
eu bürokraten
sie sahen dj fremdscham mit seinem hit
österreicher können nicht rappen ja das
stimmt aber okay ich meine der strache
ist wahrscheinlich die geschichte oder
vorsicht welche er auch für korrupte
typen die mit der rose denken gibt es
einen markt der trump ist präsident
geworden trotz seines papier an die
pussy videos gut was am fall strache
wirklich ulkig ist er hatte die falle ja
fast schon gewittert ihr ein journalist
der das ganze video gesehen hat er hatte
einmal gesagt dass exakt falle das ist
eine falle die füße die frau hat die
schmutzige fußnägel und eine russin in
der liga die hat keine schmutzige füße
fällt immer auf etwas stimmt nicht
altes österreichische sprich war ist die
magie schlägt war die hose nicht
[Applaus]
aber sagen sie mal wo sie jetzt
österreicher sind wie geht es denn jetzt
weiter da ist das land noch regiert oder
sind wir auf dem weg in die
bananenrepublik deutsche arroganz dass
piquet oberlehrer gehabe österreich
dagegen das ist lebensfreude pur spaßbad
relevant sagt sag ich selbst habe
übrigens gleich ein date mit einer
jungen oligarchen nicht die sicher die
rente grüße ich alle schätze ich muss
mich entschuldigen
meine fußnägel sehen und ich
katastrophal aus ja das macht doch
nichts ich habe meinen hornhaut obel
dabei mein arzt hat mir verboten mich
weiterhin so aufzuregen
deswegen wollte ich euch allen einfach
nur einen schönen tag menschen überall
lassen ihre risiken liegen und ihr lasst
jetzt slx ein beschissenes abo da
[Musik]